.
YOUHT. MOVE ONO A
SECOND. OF ATI
AROUND SINAI B
ITS CONSERVATIVEENOM OSOUNTRY.
LAST MONTH I RORAN WS IBO THEOMT
.REERHED EWAL'S
FA B OBOOFF
DAYOT IRE WHSSINST MANARHA SEIAB
B O A AMEOU I TMATO
S.LYIRIA TUTOKERVIE,N.IOCE  C WC
RYT . YRAOR AENO  I GPP HLDS PEY
M B'SN?ONHIE HHIYSI
ANYOULITARETRPOT'ETRO20 AV  . T
CE TEIMEF PSTTH ZENTAL MLLVA0EH.
IS S C
HA E'
RT
LEINOSRI
LVEG S I
RO
LRN HATINTA.IZES S BL
LEWI TEELET PREES TIK N HG  O Y
A OS,COTAS
SIADASSU
OUITIOK LKEPINSATAE OOC
SC D
OR Y  PO WPIVEBU  SRO A
ATHYHATH
E.EWAS
--OV THI.BUDOBOFYONC.
STTSENSOFIN LGGETINEGR MAL YMAON
EAESPEOUIVTH
PLN PIT
INS.LOUA ISJUTE S>>LA SSEM
HAG,AL'S IP AOURE IIR>>Y,.AS T
IE PGCA
LL
ST
OC M
PPPE OCTAN PRMT I I ADEP' O TT'N
SHESEVAT O PNG,LS
G TE THOP A NOSE COFPI GEE>>HAO]
CY RT'DE  TE YOW WOR TER
IOF OL  T A, N HNTYIS OFULEBOEI
EQ
HI B,HINSTHITOK
IAFNGEAENDITNGN.ED EUI
S.
EES,,EICLA TL TD V.TLIA>>XT
RERE ITN S WINALHOHEME F